this is what Christian 3 says and it
looks really really different so let me
show you how the same knowledge can help
you in a situation which looks
remarkably change from what we had
before but you can still work it out
sine alpha equals 5 on 13 so they tell
you what this ratio is you don't know
what alpha is it's some angle and then
they tell you that alpha and beta are
what are they they are their
complementary angles okay so that means
that's a signal to you that you can use
this information okay find cos beta okay
well I'm gonna write it like this
Veta beta that's that Greek letter it's
a B with a tail on it okay
cos beta is equal to now have a look at
it right because cos beta is over here I
can say this is sine of have a look have
a look this is this situation here right
it's gonna be the complement of beta
which is 90 minus beta so make sense so
in fact this line here that I've just
written is a direct use of this just
with things dressed up with different
letters betas instead of videos okay so
that's all I've changed but 90 minus
beta I can work out what that is have a
look at this guy over here which was
given to us in the question there's a 90
minus beta hiding in there
can you see it what do I have to do to
find it I'll come to 90 miles out for a
second but if I were to get 90 minus
beta most directly I should subtract
feed are from both sides shouldn't I
that'll leave me with alpha over here
yeah and 90 minus beta on the right hand
side do you see that you see how I've
subtracted beta from both sides so 19
minus beta was hiding up in here I just
needed to tweak it a little bit to see
it okay so therefore I can write this is
sine alpha
do you read you see how I've just done a
substitution but you know what sine
alpha is
it's five on 13 okay do you see how I've
gone about that
so from this line to this line I have
used in a sense I've used the definition
of sine cosine right that and that are
complementary angles and that's what
cosine means and then from here to here
what I do can you ever look up up here I
had to subtract B from both sides to
find 90 minus beta in the given
information and then I substituted you
know I'll just write that for you okay
ah this of course is given so I don't
see anything there okay okay
now this is where then gets a bit more
challenging and you need to use a bit of
imagination okay we've got cosby dun dun
now where am i - is this guy cos alpha
how do I work this out solve on question
three still I've just worked out the
first part but there's three okay three
parts here's what I'm gonna do now to
use my imagination I'm gonna recognize
that I've got this tree gray here sign
and I've got these two angles that are
complementary that means I can put them
inside a right-angled triangle can't I I
should be able to do this if I make this
which one am I going to choose alpha and
beta do you see here alpha and beta add
up to 90 because they're in a right
angle triangle okay so in fact let me
just write for your sake what what I'm
doing I'm gonna construct a right angle
triangle and I'm going to construct it
with the angles I've been provided with
alpha and beta there it is
okay help me out guys
I've got my triangle I've got this piece
of information how do I put this piece
of information up the top on this
diagram if sine alpha is 5 on 13 where
did the 5 and 13 belong in this diagram
let me give you some names just to help
you let's call this triangle PQ which
side is which so sine is opposite and
hypotenuse opposite on hypotenuse yeah
so therefore the 5 is going to be
opposite alpha do you see that its
opposite alpha so fives on this side
does that make sense do you see how I
got that Jacob Brian Jake this is hard
you're gonna ask me this question you
know five minutes Chris you don't pay
attention let me rewind so we're all on
the same page this is the information
you've got but what I'm trying to do is
look at it from different angles that's
what this was about 90 minus beta wasn't
in the original question but I can find
it in there if I look at it from a
different angle there's no triangle in
the original question Eva but I can find
one in there that fits all this
information so I've just drawn it okay
so I'm imagining it
lastly sine alpha that's opposite or
hypotenuse that's what sign means so
I've looked at alpha and I've said
that's the opposite side that's opposite
alpha and where's the hypotenuse which
side is it it's got a name it's got a
name it's PR that's 13 do you see it
sine alpha equals opposite on hypotenuse
let me label that as hypotenuse okay
have a look at what we found here cos
beta do you see why cos beta is also 5
on 13 have a look at the diagram now
because it's I use my complementary
relationship right but you can see it's
just adjacent on hypotenuse when you're
standing at beta does that make sense
see how the angle is different you see
that okay so now I'm almost there and
this is this is why I've shown you this
example cuz it's hard ok now I want to
find cos alpha
well where is cos alpha in this diagram
have a look at where is it it's got a
name cos alpha it's going to be adjacent
on hypotenuse do you agree adjacent on
hypotenuse now I know what the
hypotenuse but I don't know what the
adjacent side is how do I find it
Pythagoras thank you about Chi go ahead
can you work it out can you tell me what
this side PQ is use Pythagoras you can
find it 25 plus 144 is 169 so 5 12 13
yep say it again
should be exactly 12 should be bang-on
12 yeah I think maybe something wasn't
squared anyway okay so now I can work
out and finally there I can work out
what cos alpha is it's adjacent on
hypotenuse so let's write that cos alpha
is adjacent on hypotenuse yeah sine beta
is the last one but coincidentally or
not coincidentally it's the same can you
see why
not exactly the answer that was in my
head but that's okay all right it's a
it's opposite on hypotenuse but from a
different angle but literally from a
different angle
okay beta is that alpha also because
alpha beta are complementary remember
that that's what we looked at a beaut